[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
what's up prof
hello walter hi martin are you doing
well
yes i think i have kermit a little bit
more under control
let's hope he doesn't crack too much no
great great
we continue with an interesting one
today
that really affects every person
yes planet we just want to
do this little series to show
how all of the planning
of decades and millennia
is coming to a head in the time that we
are living in
and this alone should tell people where
we are
in the stream of time it might sound to
some like
history or something that
doesn't directly affect us but it does
because it is so invasive
in your personal life that
we need to talk about these things yes
and for some people that might
get discouraged because we continue on
this whole trend of pope francis the
whole time
we every time you'll realize we bring in
stuff that's relevant for today as well
because that's how it should be you
should see how this has been progressing
through the ages
and how it's culminating right now
correct so bear with us but you have
this is very important that we get
through all of this yes
because if we forget the history we
won't understand the present
correct let's open with the word of
prayer
hey heavenly father thank you so much
for
giving us the opportunity to have a
discussion again we ask that you bless
us and enlighten our minds and
we ask this in jesus name amen amen
well martin we're continuing with the
implementation
of a plan of the ages
just like god had a plan in the
beginning for
the plan of salvation so the enemy had a
plan
as well and these two plans are
in opposition to each other
and are meeting in the ultimate clash
in the time that we are living in so
it's very important
that we understand where this comes from
because
the devil is a master of deception
yes in other words he will implement a
plan
that seems good yes definitely
but is the direct opposite
of what god stands for it is the
negation of god
under the pretext of being for god
yes and that's so true because if you
read
some of these articles it's so
sugar-coated
and it sounds so nice yes and like we've
mentioned in the previous one
if it doesn't look problemsome
look deeper like you said the chameleon
doesn't change
it's a cover absolutely we're going to
look at natural law
education and economism all three of
them are actually
majors we could do
50 60 lectures on this and we wouldn't
exhaust the topic because it is
it runs so deep yeah if you just take
the system of education that we have in
the world where does it come from
how has it been implemented in the in
the current
state if you think back in history
all universities were
started basically as church schools yes
and what are they today the exact
opposite
everything that is biblical
that is associated with god
has been removed from the curriculum
and the opposite implanted where does
that come from
the entire model of education
i mean i'm running ahead now it's fine
it doesn't matter but
the entire model of education comes from
the gregorian university in rome the
jesuits
and i know it sounds like a broken
record when we say that
but this is a fact they
are the champions of the
counter-reformation
in other words it is their job to
destroy what the
reformation raised up
and natural law which comes way
back from way back in history
somehow must be integrated into this
and then finally echomenism which is the
ultimate brainwashing
correct because if you use natural and
education to brainwash people then
ecumenism is so much easier to
accomplish
correct so we've set the stage
let's have a look let's go back to the
previous
papacy just to show how important
the issue of natural law is to the roman
catholic church
now we've done lectures or i've done
lectures on this in the past but it's
necessary just to recap
so we just get a basic idea
so when pope benedict was at the united
nation
he denounced the go it alone superpower
strategies for global problems
in other words he wants a one-world
government he wants a unity
now in new york pope benedict the 16th
yesterday upheld the united nations as a
crucial defender of human rights
and a force for peace while warning that
unless those human rights are considered
god-given they will be subject to
erosion and revocation
now martin i know we've said this many
times but let's just
recap again human rights are the
antithesis of god's law
sugar again to look as though they are
in harmony with god's law
now there are human rights that god is
absolutely
for it is your human right to have
freedom of choice
yeah right and god was prepared to die
for that
but your freedom of choice
in these minds of these people is
limited to the common good which is
defined by
rome and contrary to the word of god
so the first commandment says you shall
have no other gods beside me
human rights says you have no right to
interfere in any man's religion
or run down or counter any
other religion or their deity
so in other words the commandment of
human rights says you will consider all
gods as equal
yeah and that's what they're bringing
into education
into the curriculum you see how the one
is linked to the other
so now in schools in california the
children have to chant
certain prayers to pagan deities
because that is the way it is everybody
has
part of the mosaic so if you go through
human rights the idea of you shall have
no other gods but the one who brought
the israelites out of egypt
that's highly problematic you're not
allowed to have idolatry it is your
human right
to worship in the form that you want to
therefore idolatry must
be acceptable all right yep
and you may blaspheme no deity except
christ it seems to me when you listen to
the media and the movies
that's correct right yeah so it must be
your human right to blaspheme christ but
it's not your human right to say
anything about any of the other
religious deities correct
yes then you would have a riot yeah and
some places might be burnt down right
so this is all very fascinating honor
your father and your mother
no in in human rights
child rights stands above parental
rights it's a reversal of god's order
thou shalt not kill yeah well
what about all the abortion laws that
you may even terminate the life of a
child while it is in the birth canal
or some are arguing even up to three
months later yeah
so all of those laws which are based on
your human rights
means nothing yeah negates the
correctness
in one of the most anticipated stops on
his u.s
tour pope benedict told the un general
assembly
that the rights encoded in the u.n
1948 universal declaration of human
rights
applied to everyone by virtue
of the common origin of the person who
remains the high point
of god's creative design for the world
and
for history now
basically that's correct we all have a
common origin
the bible makes it quite clear that by
one blood he created all of humanity
but that doesn't mean that all of
humanity is in harmony with god
yeah correct they are based
on the natural law
inscribed on human hearts and present in
different
cultures and civilizations and here's
the key
human rights are based on natural
law and we need to know
exactly what that means
his six day visit was in response to an
invitation to speak to the assembly
as pope john paul ii and paul vi
had done before him he built on their
themes of peace and human rights
human rights the pope said are the key
to
world peace and security
again here we have a philosophy
a natural law philosophy because human
rights are based on natural
law in juxtaposition to the ten
commandments
correct and even this natural law is
inscribed on your human heart
correct where the commandments are
supposed to be inscribed
correct and they come from the divine
heart so again we have this
clash the one form against the other
this is very important that we
understand that because
if he claims that they are god-given
and they are contrary to the
commandments of god
then which god gave them correct
when he was on this world mission he
also
went to the german bundestag which is
the government
and made a speech there and this is
fascinating
so this man went to
the political arena
to the united nations and to the
individual countries particularly in
europe and the united states where this
information had to be disseminated
now what did he say there and this is
very interesting here was his
apostolic journey to germany as it was
described
in 2011.
and this is in german so i'm not going
to read it in german that's pointless
but i'll summarize it
he's basically saying to the government
that by letting him speak
in this forum that they are thereby
recognizing his role
as representing the papal
chair basically the ex-cathedral yes
cathedral from the bishop's chair
so he's recognized they are recognizing
him
as a partner
inside the nations
is interesting because church and state
have to come together
and then he continues and says this is
necessary
for the judicial
development of humanity
it is paramount
that this recognition should be
also in the judicial field in other
words in laws and legislation
this is really fascinating so here you
have
a pope attending
governmental institutions and explaining
what his role is and what their duty is
in terms of his role yeah and here is
his address
to the congregation for the doctrine of
the faith now
for those who do not know what that is
this
is the body within the roman catholic
church
that determines doctrine okay
so this is the one where doctrine
is explained and presented
to the world now this is what he said to
that meeting
informing their consciences the faithful
must
pay attention to the sacred and certain
teaching of the church
martin does that bring to mind
infallibility yes
okay for the catholic church is
by the will of christ the teacher of
truth
it is her duty to proclaim and teach
with authority
the truth which is christ and at the
same time to declare
and confirm by her authority
the principles of the moral order which
spring from human
nature itself martin
that clarifies it completely
her authority comes from infallibility
yeah
she cannot uh we've discussed that
then she says she's proclaiming the
truth which is in christ
now we have to be very careful with
christ
because there are many christs
but the one that is not in harmony with
the law and the testimony
is not the true christ correct and then
quite plainly she says that she has to
confirm by
her authority the principles of the
moral order
which spring from where martin natural
law
from natural law from human nature
itself
now i thought human nature was fallen
yes
so would you like to get your morality
martin from your fallen human nature no
i think if we did that then we have the
situation that we have in the world
today
that is exactly why we are where we are
exactly so martin this is
again one of those sugar-coated pills
that is so diabolical
that it's unbelievable now here
is his address at the university of rome
so martin we've seen him in the
political arena
he's obviously in the church arena is he
now in the education arena yep 100
all right let's have a look you see
they're all linked together you can't
separate
this and this is what he said
the pope is first of all the bishop of
rome
and as such in virtue of apostolic
succession
from the apostle peter he has
episcopal authority in regard to the
entire
catholic church the word bishop
episcopas
with which in its immediate meaning
refers to
supervision all right
so what has he done in his first
sentence
he elevates his stature he's the boss
he's the supervisor
and he claims apostolic succession and
infallibility already in the new
testament was fused together with the
biblical concept
of shepherd now martin
who becomes the shepherd now the pope
the pope is the shepherd and he's the
supervisor
yes now the word there actually
for bishop is overseer
now the little horn had eyes
and a mouth speaking great things it was
the overseer
he is the one who from an elevated point
of observation
now martin who gave him that elevated
point of observation
he himself he himself
because christ said you are all one yes
there was no elevation of one over the
other exactly
surveys the whole landscape making sure
to keep the flock together
and on the right path this description
of the bishop's role
directs the view first of all
to within the community of believers
so he's talking to the church he's very
careful
to keep it generic so that it stays
ecumenical
but this community that the bishop cares
for as
large or small as it may be lives in the
world
its conditions its journey its example
and its word
inevitably influenced the rest of the
human community
in its entirety so does his role
apply only to the church no no the whole
community in his entirety that's
political and everything
thus the pope precisely as the chap
shepherd of his community has
increasingly become the voice of ethical
reasoning
of humanity of humanity there we have it
we've even heard john kerry utter the
similar
similar words so the political world has
acknowledged
this statement yes so martin let's go
to a public encyclopedia wikipedia
which is not exactly the be all and end
all of sources but even
here they have it right so
what is natural law it's greek
philosophy
emphasize the distinction between
nature on the one hand and law custom or
convention on the other
what the law commanded varied from place
to place but what was by
nature should be the same everywhere
the law of nature would therefore have
had the flavor
more of a paradox than something which
obviously
existed aristotle is often said to be
the father of
natural law so martin
is it based on the bible or is it based
on greek philosophy
greek philosophy okay once again
we get back to the conglomerate beast
the leopard
component yes which is the body last
time we
had the medium-persian law that's
unchangeable now we've got the greek
philosophy
correct so let's just find out how
important the world
regards natural law
here we have a jew
alan wolfe who was jewish professor at
boston college and he's referring to the
importance of
the catholic teaching which is
interesting yeah he said among catholic
intellectuals
as well as some who are not catholic the
most important catholic inheritance is
the natural law
tradition which is premised on the idea
that there are certain truths in the
world that remain
true irrespective of whether the laws
and conventions
of any particular society adhere to them
at its worst belief in natural law can
lead to ideological rigidity
and inflexible inhumanity
but at its best respect for natural law
gives one the self-confidence
that makes possible the passion and
curiosity that fuels
intellectual inquiry natural law in
short
inoculates us against postmodernism
that's a very interesting statement
catholics are likely to hold that the
truth of god's existence
must mean the truth of man's reason
art beauty and morality's universality
so martin this is very well put the
moral stature of humanity comes from
man it comes from man's reason
he's the one that has the capacity to
create beauty and morality
again it comes from the human heart yeah
it
negates god now here is uh
richard m gula this is a jesuit view
and he says natural law is central to
catholic theology
straight out of the horse's mouth the
advantage of using
natural law is that the church shows
great respect for
human goodness and trusts the human
capacity
to know and choose what is right
margin this is the exact
antithesis of the biblical view
man has a fallen nature
and he does not have the capacity to set
a moral compass
therefore god sets the moral compass
and he is the one that wants to instill
his moral compass
in the heart yes and that moral compass
elevates this model compass
cannot elevate above the human
capacity which is fallen
so this is a negation of god what god
said
god said you will surely die this says
no you will be as god
yeah you will set the moral compass
also by means of appealing to natural
law
the church can address its discussions
and claims for rightness or wrongness
of particular action to all persons of
good will not just to those
who share its religious convictions
in other words it cuts across all
of society whether you're an atheist or
not doesn't matter we saw that in
vatican too right
now where does the moral compass reach
its apex yes because it can't come it's
not coming from the bible
no so where is it coming from all right
does it come from
the low lens of humanity or does it come
from someone with an
elevated position that one
the magisterium that's the hierarchy of
the roman catholic church
has appealed to natural law as the basis
for its teachings pertaining to a just
society
sexual behavior medical practice
human life religious freedom
and the relationship between morality
and civil law how much does that cover
everything everything
even your most private
activities everything is covered in any
case the development of natural law
tradition among christian thinkers
is due not so much to the scriptures
as to the influence of greek philosophy
and roman law
martin there you have it yeah there you
have it out of the mouth of a jesuit
it's got nothing to do with the bible it
is based on greek for
philosophy and roman law now those two
[Music]
putting philosophy
and roman law into
a union is what called rana said
yeah it's putting philosophy into the
field
of human legislation
therefore making law that which is
contrary to god
correct and again who's choosing
the leadership the magisterium so
unfortunately you've
got that same problem right through the
bank in every
society at this stage correct leadership
are running everything absolutely and
subject to this higher supervision
let's hear what the jesuits have to say
on this issue
further pre-critical use of scripture
we may have to be absolutely sure
the catholic moral tradition has laid
claim
to two sources for acquiring moral
knowledge
scripture and natural law
now we have to be careful yeah let's see
because it has been so concerned with
finding a
common ground for moral life with which
all people could endorse catholic
tradition has given
prominence to the natural law
as the primary source of modern
knowledge
martin what has he just said it just
says the bible is secondary and it's
there for
just to glance over you know
i grew up in a catholic milieu
and i attended the catechism classes
regularly
at the school where i was and
uh i never got a bible
only a catechism yeah it's not important
you don't need the bible
so this will fall in that we can't use
that book for any history lessons or any
moral lesson nothing we have to go
through forget about that book
well it gives the appearance of a
biblical grounding to moral theology
remember gives the appearance
of a biblical ground for moral theology
proof texting really does not
allow scripture to enter the fabric of
moral theological reflection
if people don't wake up now
they will never wake up
and martin within our own ranks there
are people that say that this
system has changed and represents
christianity and represents the god of
the universe
i don't know what to say i'm sorry i
don't know how to
even address people that think like that
because of their being subject to
historical conditioning
biblical texts must be interpreted in
order to be
applied to contemporary situations
all right and i said it all correct now
if the bible says something
mata which is contrary to what they are
saying yeah
the bible has to be reinterpreted
this sounds so familiar the bible is
written for a time like that
yes it's not written for our day no so
anything that is contrary to what
natural law says so
let's see how they unpack this further
exegetical task so in other words how do
you read your bible
the exegetical task seeks to determine
what the text
meant in its original setting that's
correct that's the definition of
exegesis
does saint paul have the same reality in
mind when he condemns homosexuality
as we have in mind when we use the term
in the light of our understanding of
psychology and anthropology
all right now this is how you argue now
the bible obviously condemns something
that natural law approves of yeah
now who has to give way the bible have
to be seen
like they said no maybe that was just
written for that time we must take it
into
context now okay as a result we need to
be
modest about the claims we make when
appealing to the bible
in moral reflection so modest in fact
that you throw it into the waste paper
basket
now let's take this through to education
sex education in the schools today
based on natural law or based on the
bible
not natural are you sure yeah definitely
absolutely
are there many christians in the world
that are upset because of the way
in which education is run in the world
yes where does it come from martin
from the hierarchy which is the roman
catholic one
and the roman catholic church has no
influence on us
but the world is steeped in this
philosophy
and it is directly contrary to god
so now we go to the human ethical task
that is preaching what you basically
understand out of the bible
homiletics not exegesis
so the hermeneutical seeks to establish
the meaning of the text for today
which is not going to be the same as the
meaning
as put down and and and better storm
martin
let us use a dynamic equivalent
translation
anyone that you like as long as it's not
direct because you know
we really find it so hard to twist
what god said into our natural law
philosophy so let's rather read a bible
translation that
makes it easier for us that is already
predigested
in terms of natural law for example
we do not live consciously waiting for
an imminent
end to the world as a new testament
period did this eschatological view
influences the way we interpret the
radical demand of jesus proclamation of
the reign of god so martin
you're not waiting for the end of the
world it's not going to come
whose philosophy is that the bibles all
the roman catholics
definitely the roman catholic one they
believe in a millennialism
in other words there will be no end the
church will rule
and that is where we're heading martin
this slide says it all
we could actually go home yeah
but let's not do that now that was the
roman catholic church
yep can we see but it's only them isn't
it
no it's only them yeah we don't have to
worry about it right even though it's in
our schools it's in our education
it's in our legal system it is
everywhere
don't worry about it it's no problem
well let's go to the christian institute
this is the new archbishop of york
and this is the anglican tradition
and he says the bible has to fit the
current culture
is that exactly the same as the jesuit
just said
100 even to the point of bringing out
gender neutral bibles yes
yes it has to fit to the current culture
exactly
so reinterpreting scripture while bishop
cottrell did acknowledge biblical
passages spoke about the issue he said
they were
merely part of our story and our
inheritance
but what we can do is recognize that
what we know
now about human development and human
sexuality
requires us to look again at those texts
to see what they are
actually saying to our situation
for what we know now is not what was
known then isn't it a pity that paul was
so uninformed yeah i'm so sorry
if he'd only known about natural law he
could have been unconfused
it's amazing to me how they make the
people of the bible and
previous generations millennia ago
stupid
all scripture is written for
our admonition and it's god breathed yes
martin the protestant world
and the catholic world have now decided
to play
the same instrument yeah that's what
they're doing
let's go back to our jesuit
richard m goula he says since this
approach
maintains that the law is to reflect
what nature demands
it supports translating a model teaching
into a matter of law church and state
coming together
it's not just greek philosophy roman law
and roman law must be the basis of all
the legal systems of the world
the common understanding of the law is
defined by
saint thomas now we're going back
to saint thomas aquinas in ordinance of
reason promulgated by competent
authority for the sake of the common
good
this is the same guy that said you can
steal you can steal
so the competent authority is referring
to is not god
but someone who sits ex catitra on the
papal chair
in his cathedral position
for the rationalists something is
commanded because it is good
the rationalist perspective commonly
identified
with thomas aquinas has interpreted
strictly the elements pertaining to
law reason and common good whereas it
has
interpreted broadly the elements
pertaining to the law giver
promulgated and competent authority
so basically what he is saying is that
our
our law our morality comes out of reason
comes out of the human capacity and then
he talks about the one who is the
the law giver who is of course the
bishop of wrong
that brings us to education we've
already alluded to the fact
that this philosophy is the basis of our
modern
education yes martin
if you are concerned about the souls of
your children
then perhaps with this education that we
have in the world today homeschooling
might be
not a bad idea no so let's go to the
education issue remember the pope spoke
to the united nations
and that they should be the driving
force yes so
the new education is the education based
on
natural law and human reason human
capacity
and must be introduced to all schools
yeah yeah i remember in in our country
i think it was in the year 2000 or just
prior they had this curriculum 2000
that the whole system of ourselves
everything has to change
correct now let's just go back into
history just to get the origin of this
yutant the former secretary general of
the united nations said the world will
not change and find peace if there is
not a new education
but it's an issue of tolerance if your
natural law
tells you that your lifestyle even if it
is totally contrary to the biblical one
is not going to be accepted by some
then those some will have to change in
order to
bring about the common good right
and the change is never up
to jerusalem it's always down
to jericho yes
the former director of the world health
organization dr
brock islam stated to achieve world
government
it is necessary to remove from the minds
of men
their individualism loyalty to family
traditions
national patriotism and religious dogmas
do we find those attacked in the world
right now take any one of them
individualism does the pope rail against
individualism constantly
constantly loyalty to family traditions
family unit has been totally disrupted
and destroyed
and they railed the whole time about we
must protect the family to have them
rest on this on a race day
but then they destroy it on the other
side correct
the national patriotism is that being
destroyed oh yes
what about your religious dogmas whose
religious dogmas
anybody else except the roman catholic
church exactly so if you want to be a
protestant and believe what the bible
says we've just been told that you can't
you must set it aside and then we get to
robert muller former un assistant
secretary general
and he's the chairperson of or was of
the peace party 2000
he was called the philosopher the
prophet of hope
he was deeply spiritual and from his
vantage point
of a top-level global states person he
has seen the strong connection between
spirituality
and the political cultural scene he was
also the chancellor of the university of
peace
created by the united nations and he
created the world core
curriculum and he is known throughout
the world as the father of global
education i would like to know what the
man believed
that would be common to all yeah for the
whole world
for the common good and for
natural law so
he was the father basically of the world
core
curriculum and he received the unesco
peace education prize in 1989
and he's drawn up a framework for world
media coverage martin do we have a
framework for world media coverage
yes i'm sure everybody you know have
seen it in the pa
in the last two years no matter which
one you use they're all saying
the same thing right and if you go
contrary to them they
censor you you're censored right and a
framework for planetary and cosmic
consciousness
that scares yeah that starts getting new
age
this is very new yes and the framework
for arts and culture
in other words whatever the culture of
the society
is must be brought in and it's designed
according to new man magazine to steer
our children towards global citizenship
earth-centered beliefs socialist
values and the collective mindset which
is becoming a requirement
for the 21st century workforce martin do
we see any of those
yes the those that language is still
used exactly like that by
the pope and many other leaders that's
the world economic forum
we need earth-centered beliefs what
about socialist values that's been
pushed
isn't that being pushed down everybody's
throats
that's the common good and that is a
synthesis a
synthesis between the two
opposites communism and capitalism
and then you need a new capitalism that
is fused into
socialism all of this is coming into
effect
now this is what the preface to his
world core curriculum
said the underlying philosophy upon
which the robert mueller school
is based will be found in the teachings
set forth in the books of alice a bailey
what does that do to you that should let
you run very fast
[Laughter]
all right so alice a bailly is the one
that stepped into the shoes
of madame blavatsky the theosophy
society which elevates lucifer as the
true son of god
so this is let's put it blatantly a
satanic
core to a curriculum yep no wonder
that god-fearing people are so upset at
what is happening in the schools
correct because this is implemented
right all over the world
correct it's everywhere you cannot deny
it so the school is
certified as a united nations associated
school
providing education for international
cooperation and peace but
not even concerned about that just look
at the result is it there or is it not
it's there now what else
did he say he said open yourself to god
to the universe to all your brethren and
sisters
and to your inner self to the potential
of the human race
to the infinity of your inner self
and you will become the universe you
will become
infinity you will be at long
last your real divine stupendous self
martin is that bible-based or new
age-based that is steeped in new age
that's new age philosophy so which god
is he serving
the one that alice a bailey stood for
yep who was that lucifer
so i wonder they called their publishing
house lucifer publishing
company right yeah
now let's take this education a little
bit further enter the jesuits
did they have anything to do with the
united nations
now rome will say we've distanced
ourselves they've never distanced
themselves
from pierre thaila de shardin pier
thailat
sardine was the philosopher
in the united nations to drive this
philosophy to where it is today
and what did he say he dreamed of of
humanity
merging into god and each realizing his
own
godhood at the amiga point so that's a
new age belief
it's buddhism no wonder that the
catholic theologians
could say without buddha i cannot be a
christian
yeah paul balnetta
in fact he is one of the most quoted new
age writers
in the world and if we look at the web
pages of of the day
welcome to the global spirit the
commission
seeks to inspire consciousness of the
wholeness of the human family
and the sacred tapestry of life this
spirituality
is the foundation of a global
consciousness
that honors the wisdom found in the
world's traditions
cultures and disciplines martin is this
natural law or is this bible based
natural law and there's a big danger in
this
exactly and we're gonna get to that but
if you look at this
language that's being used also all over
the world people
must walk there's a great awakening
happening
there's a great movement
to get people awake from all the evil
that's being done
is also correct our new age movement and
when you speak about
woke i mean there are so many new terms
floating around there what is woke well
woke is concentrating your thinking
on the social issues particularly the
race issue
martin there is only one thing that can
unite humanity
and that is christ nothing else
can all that will happen is that
strife will continue to the point of
capitulation
in order to get rid of the problem you
capitulate
but it doesn't change the mind and it
doesn't change the heart
the only thing that can change the heart
is the bible
so all of this is based on
human failure
so let's look at pope francis and the
implementation
yeah all of all of this that we've seen
now that was a little bit further down
in history
yes let's see if he has strayed off from
it
correct global compact on education
bears in itself the seed of hope this
comes from the vatican news
i'm only going to read the highlighted
portion
it should present a hope that can
shatter
the determinism and fatalism of
selfishness of the strong it should
shatter the conformism of the weak and
the ideology of the utopian
at as the only way forward the pope
pointed out that education is a natural
antidote to the individualistic culture
that at times degenerates into a
true cult of the self and the primacy of
indifference very well put
but basically he's saying get rid of
your individualism yes
basically what he's saying get rid of
your god-given
right to choose your morality from the
source
that you want to choose it from yes
they will choose for you and they will
choose and it
also pertains to individualistic
countries
correct very particular when he mentions
that as well
and woke is very deeply involved in this
so he's going to
play uh the various cards at his
disposal the poverty card now poverty is
a tragedy in the world no
let's not downplay it at all but to
use it as a manipulative tool
to get rid of bible-centered beliefs
is a very dangerous thing to do
and they clever because they use it to
actually
it looks like they linking it to the
bible
because you have to love your neighbor
as yourself they use those
phrases correct but look deeper
they're not that's not the only thing
that they're pushing
the problem of hatred the problem
of clash of of civilizations
the problem of racial divides
springs from the human heart
it doesn't spring from the heart of god
god made
no distinction jesus made no distinction
whatsoever as to who he was speaking to
as long as he reached the heart
whether he was speaking to the
samaritans or whether he was speaking
to the israelites there was no change
and he said the day will come when they
will not worship on this mountain nor in
jerusalem
but you will be worshipping in
accordance with the word of god
this negates it all and sadly
uses all of these issues to create the
tension that they want the chaos
in order to create their society
so what he wants to do is he wants to
unite all of humanity we've shown the
slide many times but this is
where it's heading and the only way to
do it is to use natural law
so in other words what you are doing
which springs out of your natural
environment
is fine and we will accommodate it
and anybody who resists it on biblical
grounds
will have to be silenced
now the education that the robert miller
schools
wanted to base its curriculum on was
on the writings of alice a bailey yeah
so let's just
just just hop there quickly
alisa bailey wrote that the great heresy
and the only
real heresy is the idea that everything
is
separate distinct and different
essentially
from other things that is a
wandering from natural fact and law
for nature is nothing but coordination
cooperation
mutual healthfulness and the rule of
fundamental
unity is perfectly universal
everything in the universe lives for
everything else
it is this sense of separateness that is
the cause and the root
of evil the bible says
come out and be separate yes
and this is a call right in the
beginning of the word of god
there were the children of cain and
there were the children
of obedience yeah right and they had to
be separate from each other
eventually when you get to the time of
the hebrews
they had to be separated from their
egyptian environment
and be a separate people a holy
priesthood unto the lord
in the reformation there had to come a
separation come
out of her my people come out and be
separate there will be a final call
come out and be separate so this
is a counter call yeah
the opposite of the biblical call that
final call
hasn't it already started it has
definitely started
in fact what we are talking about right
now is
it because i have to now choose whether
i want to participate
in a world that is run on natural law
contrary to god's will which has to
reinterpret
everything that the bible says in order
to fit it into this new mole
or i have to separate it myself from it
become the pariah of the world
yes and believe what the word says
that's
it is a choice and it is the sense of
personal separateness
imagining that one is utterly separated
from all others utterly different that
prevents one
from becoming that inner god within
martin does this not take us back to the
garden of eden
yes so those two philosophies
in the beginning are coming
to the end of time and they are again
in juxtaposition and clashing one
against the other
nothing has changed this battle has been
the same
from the beginning if we go to second
corinthians
chapter 6 verse 17 wherefore come
out from among them and be ye separate
says the lord
and touch not the unclean thing and i
will receive you it's pretty clear
they call this a heresy yes right
100 that's what they call heresy
revelation 18 verse 4 and 5 and i heard
another voice from heaven saying come
out of her my people
that you be not partakers of her sins
sin
is the transgression of the law natural
law says the bible must be
reinterpreted so that sin is no longer
sin and perfectly acceptable to all of
humanity and we will teach your
children thus and if you do not conform
we will make laws to make sure that you
do
yes for her sins have reached unto
heaven and god has remembered her
iniquities
there is a call to be separate and there
is a counter call
to unity now allah say bailey
says separateness is a sin
in other words what god is saying is is
a sin yeah
echomanism does exactly the same thing
exactly can you see why we cannot
separate them
no because this was the basis natural
law
education and then you can accomplish
ecumenism
correct so back to pope francis
pope francis has a few words in support
of
leisure let's read the highlighted
portions
responding to the question do we need to
rediscover the meaning of leisure
pope francis replies together with a
culture of work
there must be a culture of leisure as
gratification
to put it another way people who work
must take the time to relax
to be with their families to enjoy
themselves
read listen to music play a sport
but this is being destroyed in large
part by the elimination of the
sabbath rest day more and more people
work on sundays as a consequence of the
competitiveness
imposed by a consumer society
in such cases he continued work ends
up dehumanizing people
the idea of a catholic exalting the
sabbath sounds particularly peculiar in
the american context
in the united states catholics were
never the great proponents of
sabbatarianism
observing sunday as a special day for
worship or rest
that was a protestant thing
martin he is so clever
he says we need a culture of rest
and then he puts the sunday in the place
and then he says but even the
protestants had this idea yes that's
actually their idea
isn't this wonderful so again
he's negating what the bible says at
every single point
they go against scripture yeah and now
they that's how they bring this
ecumenism now
it's not only us that you are saying
this the protestants also saying this so
we can be
together on this correct the next thing
he said
recently is
private property is a secondary right
but francis sent out the strong message
thursday during a video
conference with the international labor
organization
ilo when he affirmed that private
property is a secondary not a primary
right
again speaking to labor unions
again the labor unions not martin
we discussed in one of the previous
what's up
prof series the book ecclesiastical
megalomania
the roman catholic church claims the
right to
property for herself alone
and only those that
live in accordance with her ideals
have the right to private property yeah
so it's a secondary right
they have the primary right we need to
understand this
now if we go back to the bible
ahab coveted nebras vineyard yeah
and what did nebot say to ahab to the
state
it's not your right it's not yours it's
my god-given right
then what is jezebel who is a type of of
roman catholicism
because she led the people to sun
worship what did she say
don't worry i'll get it for you i'll get
it for you
and she had him destroyed that is a
typological story of what is happening
here
sometimes when talking about private
property we forget that it is a
secondary right which depends
on a primary right the universal
destination of goods
who determines how that how those goods
must be redistributed
they they do the leader of the catholic
church told the summit in geneva
we should continue exercising special
care for the common good martin
this issue is all-encompassing yeah
he has the elevated position he is the
supervisor
he determines what the common good is he
brings in
sunday he co-opts the protestants for
his sunday issue
and now he's placing property rights
on the level of common good defined by
him yes
so people must take note when there are
talks about land reformation this
is where it comes from absolutely it's
not a government or
racial thing correct it's being
coming down from the roman catholic
church correct
so the pope suggested that once the
pandemic is over
reconstruction of the world economy
should aim to include
decent and dignified working conditions
with the right to organize upheld
as a central pillar so the workers
unions
the trade unions decent working
conditions must include sunday
yeah and the right to organize means
they can protest
correct unions are an expression of the
prophetic profile of society
unions are born and reborn
so many times that like the biblical
prophets
they give a voice to those who do not
have it martin
so the trade unions are the prophetic
voice of the people
in other words they emulate
what is in the heart of the people that
has been placed there by them
through their education
have to separate from this system
so that brings us to fratelli tutti
we're all one correct all of us are one
this
ecumenism can now be born out of this
correct there must be no difference in
terms of our social thinking
there must be no difference in terms of
our religious thinking
therefore all the religions can unite i
don't
we don't even have to read further just
leave it there
all can unite because we all serve the
same god
even though some of these gods don't
have a son
the free thinker pope francis extends
a hand of friendship to atheists even
though we are disastrous for the world
this is
matthew speaking so here is a pope that
reaches out
to everyone the gospel also reaches out
to atheists
correct i was an atheist
but did the bible leave you there no
it didn't leave me there took me out
this embraces him as
he is don't change we don't need you to
change we just need you to become
part of the whole
and then pope francis uses his easter
address to denounce
greed looking for easy gain
so the pope who has sought to make
himself
the tribune of the poor disabled and
disadvantaged appeared to put
uncaring capitalism in the same category
as the armed conflict his predecessors
have traditionally
and forelonely deplored on easter day
so here again champion
of this divide in society
choosing the one downplaying the other
until you have what you finally want to
achieve
pope francis says atheists who do good
or redeemed
not just catholics was i redeemed when i
was
an atheist whereby can you go
to the father only by the name of jesus
correct if you do not utter his name
no matter how much money i gave to the
poor
no matter what i did you know what
martin
i used to think i was a good person
until i realized i was a sinner and not
until i realized
i was a sinner did i have need of a
redeemer
correct that's very important this cuts
him out
completely this philosophy is so
dangerous
all right martin so he has room for
whoever he wants to put into this net of
years right
don't change it's not necessary
the sirian right is a promising model
for the amazon now what was this all
about
so the right encourages participation
and engagement of the congregation
there's a constant back and forth
between assembly and the principle
celebrant and the congregants move
gracefully in church as an expression
both of their faith and joy whatever
culture they bring in
perfectly fine cultural vibrancy and
spirituality
a model for the amazonian right an
invitation for enculturated liturgies
not in this terminology you know liturgy
means everything to them right
everything that happens besides the
preaching of the word of god
let's bring in all of these cultures no
matter how pagan
no problem so amazonian woman who led
vatican tree planting ceremony reveals
its pagan significance
so basically she said while bowing down
around pachamama statues
during the october 4 ceremony she said
regarding the event
the senate is to plant this tree water
and cultivate so that the amazonian
people are heard
and respected in their customs and
traditions experiencing the mystery of
the divinity
present in the amazonian soil
this is earth worship yes pantheism
pantheism and it's a
so perfectly acceptable the pope
participates in the ceremony
so natural law
bringing what is natural for a society
into the society and society
has to accept it let's let's look at the
ceremony
like
now i know we've shown that one before
but it just goes to show how
all embracing the natural philosophy of
natural law philosophy is
pope and the grand imam historic
declaration of peace freedom and women's
rights we don't have to
read it all but you have quite a
combination there you have peace
you have women's rights and you have
islam and catholicism
all of them coming in that's natural law
philosophy
as opposed to come out and be separate
yes have nothing to do with the
philosophy of
egypt or the babylonian philosophies
pope francis in africa hindus attended
the mass in mauritius
now martin i am for religious freedom
yes
everybody is entitled to believe what he
wants to believe and i'm not in the game
of forcing anyone
but i will preach the gospel yes and if
i want to
be in ecumenism with you we have to
believe the same
i certainly cannot believe the same as
some
that negate the very principles of the
bible
so whether it is islam whether it is a
pagan religion
whether it is an earth-based religion
all of it is acceptable
protestants to take catholic communion
at calvin cathedral
in geneva on libya day
this is a literal sacrifice
so this is absolutely unbelievable that
a protestant
can partake of a roman catholic mass
this is the reason why the reformation
the protestant
movement was initiated
yes you are taking part in the pagan
ritual
this is babylonian sun worship because
by one sacrifice he has
forever made perfect
as pope francis said ecomenism is
achieved by
walking and then it is
cemented by sitting yeah
we are trying to walk together in the
hope that when we have made enough
progress
the obstacles that seem to us today
insurmountable will
no longer be he said so
basically what we are showing is how
all-encompassing yes
the naturals law philosophy
is the bible says can two walk
together lest they agree correct so if
they're walking together
then it means these protestants must
agree with the catholics correct
now if you take this issue of the
eucharist just
just let your mind run through the
corridors of history
protestantism threw out the catholic
mass
as pagan they threw out the altars
out of the churches because
a cathedral is a place
where you sacrifice and
we don't have a sacrifice because our
sacrifice the perfect sacrifice has been
given once and for
all so protestantism
throughout the altars there's no room
for an altar
in a christian church
anglicanism had thrown the altars out
had thrown the images out of their
churches
and then through the oxford movement and
the writings and eloquent
speaking of cardinal newman who used to
be a protestant
and then defected to catholicism under
his guidance the oxford
movement brought all of these rituals
back
and into the heart of protestantism they
brought the pagan
mass right yes
and now protestants in general
from that stepping stone are to partake
in all of this for the sake of the
common good
let us just get this quite straight
the glue to glue protestantism
traditional protestantism
to catholicism was created
in vatican ii and we've discussed the
charismatic movement
and its role in bringing them together
where the spirit becomes the norm yes
and protestants think that the
charismatic movement this pentecostal
movement
is something that came out of the heart
of protestantism
no it came out of the heart of
catholicism correct
and it is a movement that does
exactly to the bible what the jesuit
says
it should yes in other words disseminate
it
take out its power use a verse here and
there
throw it around lots of praise and all
of these
issues but listen to the spirit that is
the norm
where did it originate let's ask the
pentecostal movement
itself
the protestant reformation could also be
known as one of the largest
church splits in history what took place
in 1521 when martin luther was
excommunicated from the catholic church
opened wide the doors to the spirit of
division
since that time true unity in the church
has been nearly unheard of
with denomination after denomination and
church split
after church split jesus's prayer that
we all may be one
as seemed to be almost unattainable
however within the heart of one young
nun
the holy spirit was fanning a flame that
would spark
miraculous change blessed elena guerra
would not rest from encouraging pope leo
xiii
to establish an institutional devotion
to the holy spirit
he dedicated his pontificate to the
reunion of all
christians and on the first day of 1901
invoked the holy spirit over all
christendom
to usher in the new century that same
day in topeka kansas
the pentecostal movement sparked a flame
when a young girl began speaking in
tongues
after the invocation of the holy spirit
was given by a lay evangelist
following the 1901 pentecostal
outpouring
a revival began in 1906 on azusa street
bringing real and lasting changes in the
lives of those whose hearts were touched
years passed bringing small signs of
hope in the catholic church
just as pope leo the 13th had prayed for
an outpouring of the holy spirit in 1901
pope john xxiii prayed in 1962
for god to renew your wonders in this
our day
as by a new pentecost those prayers
finally began to come to pass
in 1967 this fresh move of the holy
spirit took place
not at the hands of the clergy but
rather among a group of catholic
students from duquesne university
it quickly spread to the university of
notre dame
and was then experienced in the catholic
church in 1970
this now worldwide charismatic movement
currently includes approximately 700
million people
of whom 160 million are catholics
this charismatic renewal grew from small
prayer groups
into national and international
conferences
the magnitude of change that was to come
because of this openness to
and welcoming of the holy spirit was not
initially known
by the holy spirit's great work those
500 year old divisional walls
are coming down the historic events at
the beginning of the charismatic renewal
are significant for unity not only among
individual christians
but also for unity in the entire
worldwide church
the separation between the catholic
church and the lutherans that began in
the 1500s
has been reversed nearly 500 years later
in 1999 through the joint declaration on
the doctrine of justification
together they stated that christ himself
is our righteousness by grace alone in
faith in christ's saving work and not
because of any merit on our part
we are accepted by god a common
understanding of justification by god's
grace through faith in christ
has built a bridge reuniting the
churches
and that is only the beginning around
the world
christians from all denominations races
and
languages are joining together and again
becoming the body of christ
it is now that we all must come unto the
unity of our faith
that the world may know that we are his
disciples
somebody ought to shout amen
[Music]
can you now see why the devil fought for
the lie
that a catholic couldn't be saved
come on this pentecostal outpouring in
our time
started in the vatican
it didn't start in azusa street it
didn't start in topeka kansas
it was a pope that invoked
faith and asked god
for a new pentecost
so martin where did the pentecostal
movement start
according to kenneth copeland in the
vatican
and by a pope by a pope
and where did it lead to a reunification
yes and based on a joint declaration
on justification which totally
distorts the doctrine of justification
because as it reads by grace alone
instead of by faith alone and through
christ's saving works instead of the
blood of the lamb
they have mingled catholicism
and caused a synergism
that is not biblical it is a very
cleverly worded document
but it is absolutely the antithesis of
the doctrine of justification
and it mingles justification and
sanctification
which is absolutely impossible and it's
also important to remember that this
that kenneth copeland was mentioning now
about the pope invoking it
brought about the speaking in tongues
movement correct
and pope paul vi when he was
addressing the issues of the vatican ii
council he spoke in tongues so this is
where
it originated it places the spirit as
the standard and the norm
and the bible is secondary so
where did it lead to well it led to the
eventual
so-called willingness to unite
back with roman catholicism who have the
same manifestation within their own
ranks we've shown this before but let's
just for clarity put it in here again
okay here's here's the deal
[Music]
i believe that the catholic church and
the christian church
are going to come together
right now father i thank you in the name
of jesus god
for a mighty baptism on the catholic
church
[Applause]
holy spirit more fire
jesus name fire of heaven
in the name of jesus we're a delegation
a catholic delegation and i come from
puerto rico
charismatic and i bring you a salute
from 150 million charismatic catholics
we want to lose kiss your feet as
catholics
and just honor you with this gesture
right now
[Music]
raise up catholics all over the world
one billion souls of catholics to come
into the kingdom of god
the hour is coming the chains are broken
the loosing of the lord upon every
single catholic in the world
that they would receive the baptism of
the holy spirit
a revival will spring forth in the
catholic church
like never before
it's obviously where the spirit has led
it has led to a union of truth and error
correct and that can never be the spirit
and that's the only way you can have
ecumenism with the roman catholic church
some we have to compromise correct so
the national catholic reporter tells us
that
pope francis has deep ties with
evangelicals
obviously he has to for the sake of
their communism we don't have to say
anything more
pope urges catholics and evangelicals to
continue working for unity
theological dialogue cannot replace the
economical importance
of christians simply sharing a meal
is obviously referring to something more
than that right correct
recognizing they are brothers and
sisters and loving one another the pope
said
the retreat is part of john 17 movement
so this
is in june 2021 yeah
that works to foster fellowship between
catholics protestants orthodox
evangelicals and pentecostals and let's
throw earth worship and all the other
major religions into the pot as well
correct
so this is where it is all
heading so now martin
let's just take it back to basics
we've heard so much about the common
good
we've seen all the elements have they
have been
intertwined in every single one of them
negating the word of god let's just go
to the roman catholic catechism
this is the catechism of the catholic
church the second edition
article 2 1 8 8 this is very important
let's read it in respecting religious
liberty and the common good
of all christians should seek
recognition of sundays and the church's
holy days
as legal holidays
they have to give everyone a public
example
of prayer respect and joy and defend
their traditions
as a precious contribution to the
spiritual life of
society if a country's legislation
or other reasons require work on sunday
the day should nevertheless be lived as
the day of our deliverance
which lets us share in this festival
gathering
this assembly of the firstborn who are
enrolled
in heaven this
is the mark of their ecclesiastical
power they have stated it
over and over again the fact that
they've shifted the solemnity from the
seventh day of the week to the first day
of the week is a
mark of their ecclesiastical
authority now it's also part of the
common good yes
so when the pope speaks about the common
good
it never excludes
sunday never never and therefore
christians must
seek recognition as
legal holidays
does the catechism ask for
sunday legislation yes
okay now given what we've seen
that it doesn't matter where you come
from
whether you're an atheist whether you
are from one of the world's major
religions
whether you are an earth worshiper
whether you are a pantheist
it doesn't matter
then this common good this
rest which is always linked to sunday
becomes part of all humanity and not
just religious
so when they bring this legal aspect
in can you bring it in through any means
pagan or otherwise enemy any means as
long as it's recognized yes
does it negate the word of god yes
is it the mark of the best yes
absolutely it's enshrined in their
catechism
that's the mark that's the mark so this
is where we're heading
and there are people martin even within
our own ranks
that say that we must redefine
how we understand the writings and the
prophets
even the last day prophets yes
and there are people that saying it's
not going to come the way that we
envisioned
these people must be exceedingly
deceived
in order to to think that the way they
are thinking
because it is very clear in these
writings well
i must say i think a lot of this that
we've just gone through
has maybe brainwashed some of them as
well all right
so obviously martin if you expose these
things
do you become an enemy of the system
definitely
definitely right yep if you go in
contrary to any of this
you're being like a taking a
marker and highlight it so let's look at
this aspect before we
wrap this thing up this is the
journal america remember that this is
the
jesuit journal in the united states of
america
the jesuit review june 23
2021 pope francis
those who insist on keeping the truth
over preaching the gospel have always
threatened the church
that's a very strange statement to make
and that
always is also showing not just now
hamarton keeping the truth in other
words those who
insist that they are keeping the truth
are a threat to
modern society yeah okay let's just
let's just highlight again the bible
defines truth as
jesus is the way the truth and the life
thy word is truth
all thy commandments are truth
yes so people who emphasize let's
rephrase this statement
that jesus is the only way yeah people
that emphasize that your morality should
be based on the bible
and people who say that the law of god
is the standard
over preaching his gospel
which is which is a very inclusive
gospel as we have seen
incorporates anything from paganism to
atheism
that they are a threat to the church
he's right
correct he's absolutely right i
certainly hope so or else those who are
preaching
particularly on the airwaves are not
doing their job
and they strongly affirm that the true
christianity is the one they adhere to
often identified with certain forms of
the past
could it be that they linger back
to the reformation yes and because they
might be referring to the ten
commandments that's supposed to be in
the past because the new
covenant has done away with it except of
course for
their version of it yes that has to be
elevated
and that the solution to the crisis of
today
is to go back so as not to lose the
genuineness of the faith
martin if we don't go back to
bible-based
christianity we will lose the plot
seek out the old paths yes seek the
ancient paths
and the lord says that he will bless you
right
one of the traces of this way of
proceeding is
inflexibility faced with the preaching
of the gospel that makes us free
that makes us joyful these people are
rigid
always the rigidity you must do this you
must do that
inflexibility is typical of these people
martin
isn't this the pot calling the kettle
black
yes isn't this the man who says you must
keep sunday
isn't this the man that says you must
tolerate
all evil or else you don't yes qualify
for the common good
you yes you have to do everything for
the common good
that's not inflexible that is
free because it's based on natural law
the new preachers do not know what
humility is
what fraternity is fraternity is
accepting everything as part of the
system
it is the path of meek and obedient
trust the new preachers know
neither meekness nor obedience
excuse me obedience to whom
to them to them martin
i hope that when it comes to the crunch
between choosing obedience to god
and obedience to their system
that we will have enough
moral integrity
not out of our own selves but from a
higher source
to a adhere to a thus says the lord
definitely
revelation 13 verse 2 and 4
and the beast which i saw was like unto
a leopard
did we see that greek philosophy yep
and his feet were as the feet of the
bear did we see that infallibility yes
middle persian
and the mithraic system where you have a
father and you have a congregation
all of it is in catholicism and his
mouth is the mouth of the lion
the babylonian religion of semiramis did
we see that
in the last presentation and
the dragon that's the devil gave him his
power and his seat in great authority do
we see that
yep and i saw one of the heads as it
were wounded to death
and the deadly wound was healed and all
the world
wandered after the beast received its
mindset
yes through the media through the new
education
went into economical councils with them
and sit
with them correct and they worship the
dragon
that's very plain when they do that they
worship the devil
which gave power unto the beast and they
worshiped the beast saying who is
like unto the beast who can compete with
this
roman catholic system who is able to
make war with him
we have come to the point of decision
either we run in this channel
or we come out of her my people
so we have the biblical injunction
be separate or the great heresy
of separateness coming up against each
other
which one are we going to choose martin
let's stay with the bible let's pray
heavenly father you have given us your
word
the word became flesh and dwelt amongst
us
and lord he was not well received in his
day
and it seems to me lord he is not well
received in our day
but as for me and my household
i pray that we will make you
the way the truth and the life
and i pray that we will not live by
bread alone but by
every word that proceeds out of the
mouth of the lord
and i pray that if we love you we will
keep your commandments and your
commandments are not burdensome
your yoke is light i thank you
for the gift of jesus the gift of the
word
and the gift of your legal system in
jesus name
amen amen
thank you for watching this video to
subscribe
click here when the bell appears
click again to get notifications to
watch the next video
click here thank you